estamos en el subway Este es el centro
de doja y quizás el lugar más
tradicional de la capital a alcantarilla
a lo largo de todo este mundial este
sitio lleno de restaurantes y de
pequeñas tiendas de productos locales se
ha convertido en el epicentro de la
hinchada aquí en Qatar 2022 y
aprovechamos que estamos aquí para
hablar con algunos de los hinchas de
Marruecos que se preparan para la
semifinal ante Francia y esto fue lo que
nos dijeron acerca de cómo esperan que
sea ese partido
y estamos muy contentos incluso que ya
hayan podido llegar a esta fase es Algo
extraordinario
yo soy Franco Marroquín viví varios años
en Francia Así que tengo el corazón un
poco dividido pero se inclina más hacia
Marruecos va a ser un partido muy
difícil para los dos equipos Marruecos
ha defendido mucho en esta Copa del
Mundo solamente ha recibido un gol en
contra pero era un gol en portería
propia Francia es un equipo muy fuerte
estamos muy orgullosos de ellos yo los
considero un poco como mis hijos yo
cuando los estoy alentando es como si mi
hijo estuviera jugando de verdad es eso
lo que nos han dado generado en nosotros
nos ponen los pelos de punta
yo in especialmente para el último
partido ante Canadá pero una vez que
Marruecos se clasificó a la siguiente
ronda pues cambié mi tiquete de avión y
sigo buscando tiquete para cada partido
para esta semifinal en el estadio del
beige esperan más de 40.000 marroquíes
que van a jugar como locales todos los
Países Árabes y africanos
de Los Leones del Atlas además de esto
la compañía nacional aérea ha dispuesto
unos 30 vuelos para que los hinchas
marroquíes puedan venir desde Casa
Blanca hasta aquí a doja y sea quien sea
Quien llegue finalmente a ese partido de
final el próximo domingo este seguirá
viviendo con la vida del fútbol